a breakthrough in research on cures for
several diseases like Alzheimer's could
depend on a rare group of primates in
danger of extensions lemurs and humans
have important genetic similarities who
knew that but the creatures survival is
at risk from major threats like
deforestation and climate change Debora
patta visited a national park in
Madagascar an island off of Africa where
she got a first-hand look she's now in
Johannesburg with more on this story
Deborah good morning morning Madagascar
is the only place in the world where
lemurs exist in the wild and while it
was thrilling to see them up close
staring right back at us it was all so
devastating to observe how climate
change is threatening their existence
six hours of hiking in the ranima Feiner
rainforest we finally spotted one of the
rarest animals in the world
a sifaka lemur one of only 2,000 left
anthropologists Pat Wright from New York
Stony Brook University told us that
lemurs share many of the same genes as
humans she's turned the islands national
park into a science lab and has been
studying lemurs for 30 years kind of
ironic that an animal that is on the
verge of extinction
could hold the key to so many
life-threatening diseases that's really
true it's like burning a library there
are over 100 different species including
the mouse lemur our smallest cousin on
the mass lemurs why do they hold such
importance for us because they get some
of the same diseases that we get
Alzheimer's is top of Wrights list her
team has embedded computer chips in
hundreds of lemurs so they can monitor
the development of Alzheimer's for an
average of 20 years she's built a
genetic data bank from her research and
her hope is it will lead to new drugs
one day but it is a race against time
lemurs cannot survive without forests
and 95% of the lemurs natural habitat
outside this park is gone
researchers bait traps to lure the mouse
lemurs inside each one is weighed and
measured they're looking for early signs
of disease or weight loss
once the tests are over the lemurs are
released unharmed
back into the wild but now they are
facing a new threat Madagascar has been
hard hit by extreme changes in weather
strong cyclones
severe drought then torrential rain and
this year like told us the fruit trees
that are the lemurs main food source did
not flower this has never happened
before
for the lemurs it's devastating because
it means they can't get fat enough to
actually produce offspring and there
probably won't starve but they certainly
are going to go hungry right is fearful
the devastating changes to the island
spell the end of her lemurs Madagascar
itself is like the canary in the coal
mine this island is very vulnerable and
so climate change makes a bigger impact
here now that canary in the coal mine
that Pat Wright spoke about is sending a
very strong warning indeed only 47
percent of the baby lemurs we saw
survived beyond six months and that was
70 percent just three years ago Nora all
right Deborah pata in Johannesburg thank
you it really sparks this debate too
about what we can learn from wildlife
animals lemurs for new yeah take a whole
the Debora patta was interested it had
me googling Madagascar 2 or apparently
90% of the wildlife there is found
nowhere else on earth it's a
biodiversity hotspot more than a movie
I've always wanted to go there though
paper changer imma change yeah field
trip